ANDRES: Good afternoon, and
welcome to our session--
Building a Business around
the Google Places API.
My name is Andres, and I am with
the Google Maps developer
relations team.
MARCELO: And I'm Marcelo with
the Places API team.
ANDRES: So our session today is
broken up into two parts.
In the first part, we're going
to do a conceptual overview.
We're going to quickly walk
through the features of the
Places API, and then we're also
going to talk about the
vision that we have for how
developers can build a
business around the
Places API.
And in the second part of the
session, we're actually going
to talk about the practical use
of features of the Places
API in building an application
that demonstrates how to build
a business.
When Marcelo and I first began
to discuss the idea for this
session, we knew that surfing
was going to be a natural fit.
Marcelo and I are both surfers,
we've talked about
the use cases around
location based
applications and surfing.
And so we quickly discovered
that this session would be a
great opportunity to showcase
a surfing application.
So we'll touch on this a little
bit later on, but keep
in mind that the theme for our
entire session is surfing.
All right, so let's talk about
the Google Places API.
As I mentioned, I'm going to
do a quick overview of the
Places API--
pretty much make sure that we're
all on the same page,
and this is also for the benefit
of those folks out
there who may not be familiar
with the API.
The API is accessible
in two ways.
One, as a JavaScript library
that's part of the Google Maps
JavaScript API, and the other
way is as an HTTP-based web
service that accepts GET
and POST requests.
Now both of these elements of
the API share some common
features and we'll touch on
these as we walk through the
application that we designed,
but I also want to touch on a
couple of things that we
announced earlier today, and
these are some features that
developers have been asking
for quite a bit.
The first is the incorporation
of reviews, so you can now get
the top five reviews that are
associated with any given
place through the API, and this
is applicable to both the
Library and the Web Service.
We've also included paging, so
that you can now get results
in sets of 20, up to
a total of 60.
And, lastly, we've included text
search, so this is more
of a natural type of a search
where you can use, for
example, "near" as a modifier,
so you can search for "pizza"
in New York City, or "coffee" in
Mountain View, California--
those types of searches.
And again, we'll come back to
that a little bit later on in
the session.
It's also worth noting that the
Web Service also provides
some additional capabilities.
We provide Place Reports, so
this is the ability to add or
delete a place, and this is
places that are specific to
your application.
You can do the same
with events.
And, lastly, we offer a check-in
feature, which really
is more of a bump.
It increases the signal, and
gives more prominence to the
places where your users are
checking in, so these are all
relative to your application.
The next thing I want to touch
on is the data that's
accessible as part of the
Google Places API.
Now, we've touched
on this before.
We have a lot of places that are
accessible as part of the
places API.
How many places?
80 plus million places.
We have global coverage,
it's quite significant.
Marcelo, I snuck this photo in
here for your benefit, you
want to tell folks
where this is?
MARCELO: Oh yeah, it is a little
bit familiar to me.
That's the beach of Ipanema,
in Rio, where I'm from.
It's beautiful.
ANDRES: Yeah.
I was there about a month ago
for two days, but I made sure
that on one of those days I
went for a run, and got to
know some of the places
around there as well.
So we've got places like
Ipanema, you can actually
access all different types
of places using the API.
And this is great, so you can go
to a place, you can search
by proximity, you can see what's
around you, but in
addition to providing sort of
this base information, We also
have some extended details that
are associated with the
places in our API, and this is
kind of what boils down to
providing intelligence
to your users.
So we have things like
structured address
information, we have things
like ratings, I mentioned
reviews, we also have the
contact information, and much
more information about
all these places.
So we have global coverage,
different types of places--
I think it's over 100 different
types of places,
right, Marcelo?
And extended details for
all these places.
When I was preparing for this
session I figured it'd be good
to put together a demo, and so
I just sort of off the top of
my head started thinking about
different types of places that
I could search for
around the world.
So the first place that I
searched for, of course, was
Rio de Janeiro.
MARCELO: Thank you.
ANDRES: Marcelo keeps raving
about how good the food is
back in Brazil and--
MARCELO: It is.
ANDRES: --I have to agree, now
that I've been in Rio, that
that is the case.
I spent a significant amount of
time in Portland, Oregon,
back in the day, as it were,
and so I figured I'd search
for bookstores because I
know there's a lot of
bookstores in Portland.
And I would be remiss if I
didn't mention Powell's City
of Books, which is a bookstore
that takes up about an entire
city block-- it's three
stories high.
If you ever make it
to Portland, this
is a must see place.
Gas stations in Tokyo,
you can see some
geographic patterns here.
Of course there's not going to
be any gas stations in the
southern part, in Chiyoda,
in that precinct.
I looked for schools in Bangkok,
and, lastly, I looked
for hotels in Cairo.
I think you guys get
the idea, right?
We have a lot of places around
the world, it's very
easy to find them.
Next, I'm going to demo--
and this is a live demo, so at
the risk of doing a live
demo-- but I want to talk about
the autocomplete feature
and just how really neat
this feature can be.
What we've done here is we've
provided just an input field
here, and we also have your
typical online address form
where all of the fields are
broken out into different
input boxes.
By the way, who out there has
not ever entered address
information into a web page--
to an online form like this.
All right.
Who out there enjoyed it?
OK.
All right, so it dawned
on me this morning--
as I was coming up to San
Francisco because I live down
in Mountain View-- it dawned
on me this morning that I
should really look up the
address for Moscone Center.
I know the landmark--
I've been here many times-- but
it actually dawned on me I
don't know the address, so let's
search for the address.
It's 580 Howard Street.
And this is a predictive type
of a search, right?
So it's going to try
to guess what it is
that I'm looking for.
So as I type in characters
you'll see that, OK, it's
thinking I'm looking for maybe
5800 Techni Center in Austin.
Sounds like a cool place, but
that's not really what I'm
looking for.
And as I advance, you'll see
that after seven characters
it's already sort of predicted
and found the place that I'm
looking for.
And once I select that, I can
use the JavaScript library and
pre-populate those fields.
So I mean, this is a really
neat feature, I think your
users will thank you time
and time again.
And you're giving them,
essentially, access to all
these millions of places in
just a few keystrokes.
But that's not really
it, right?
I mean, we need to talk a little
bit more about our
vision, right, Marcelo?
MARCELO: Yeah, that's correct.
And it is a pleasure to be here
today to talk about the
Places API, but since I first
learned-- let me introduce
myself again, before that.
My name is Marcelo, and I'm
the lead engineer for the
Places API team in Sydney.
And I want to tell you since I
first learned I would be here
at Google I/O to talk about
the Places API, I've been
looking forward to the
opportunity to talk about the
long term vision that our team
has for the product.
It all starts with the
realization that technology is
really reshaping people's
behavior--
the way we shop, the way we
work, the way we communicate
with each other.
And that's, of course, old
news when it comes to the
online aspects of our lives,
but also increasingly we're
seeing technology, especially
mobile, having an impact on
how we interact with the
physical world around us--
in the way we learn about new
places, the way we discover
our surroundings, and also how
we make decisions about where
to go, and even about how to
spend our time and money.
And we see that as an
opportunity to have a huge
impact for the good on people's
lives and to make
that at a real large scale.
And that's our goal with the
Places API, but, of course,
the challenge of realizing this
vision is much greater
than just Google, and that's
where developers
come into the picture.
We know that it's going to take
a great amount of effort
and innovation, entrepreneurship
from both
small and big players to make
this vision come true.
But we also know that this
kind of large scale
distributed efforts, they
usually tend to revolve around
ecosystems, and that's what the
Places API is all about.
The Places API is about creating
the conditions and
the incentives for such
an ecosystem to
flourish and prosper.
The API is a first step towards
enabling an ecosystem
of location based services
and applications.
So that's our vision, right?
And based on this vision,
I want to touch on--
thank you--
I want to touch on four basic
principles that not only guide
our thinking when we designed
the Places API, but also
possibly relate it to creating
interesting location based
applications--
an application that'll make the
life of your users better.
And that's how you want your
app to described if you're
trying to build a business
out of it.
So the first principle is
a very fundamental one--
the specialists do it better.
We believe that an app that is
highly specialized has a
better chance at meeting its
users expectations and needs
when compared to an app that
is a generic app--
one that tries to be everything
to everyone.
The more specialized an app
is, the better it can
understand its user and its use
case, and the more insight
it can have on the data
that it's serving.
And as I said, it's a very
fundamental principle and it
permeates this entire session.
So principle number two--
the base data is not enough.
And when I say this, I'm
actually trying to say the
Places API is not enough,
and I'll give you
two reasons for that.
First, the Places API data is
generic by nature, by design,
because it has to work for every
type of application that
you guys came up with.
And the second reason--
and you have to keep that in
mind at all times-- is
whatever data your app is
getting out of the Places API
is easily accessible to
competing products.
So if all your app's doing is
getting data out of the Places
API and passing it to your
users, you're not really
differentiating your app
in terms of data in any
meaningful way.
You're not really giving your
user a reason to stick to your
application instead of using
a competing product.
So that's why you have to go
beyond the base data, you have
to try to differentiate
your application.
And that takes us to principle
number three--
finding is greater
than searching.
Always keep in mind, searching
is standing between your user
and what the task is trying
to accomplish.
Search has a cost in terms
of the time and effort--
[? productive ?] effort-- for
your user, so you've got to
design your app in a way that
you're minimizing the time
that your user spends
searching.
And in addition to paying close
attention to your UI and
automating as much as you can,
you also have to have a deep
understanding of your user's
intentions, a deep
understanding of your use case,
and a deep understanding
of the data-- of the
specialized data--
your app is serving.
And that bring us back to,
again, principle number one--
the more specialized your
application is, the easier
time it's going to have to have
that kind of insight.
And now before I go into
principle number four, let me
step back and look at the idea
of the ecosystem again.
First, you have Google, who is
collecting and indexing all
sorts of local data and making
the data easily available
through the Places API.
Next, you have you--
developers--
creating great local apps that
consume data out of the Places
API, but also augmented with
your own specialized data that
you, also, yourself collect.
Next, you've got users who use
those apps to go out in the
real world, explore, discover
new places, but also make
decisions, especially
purchase decisions.
Who is missing from
this picture?
AUDIENCE: Merchants.
MARCELO: Exactly.
You, sir, are paying
attention.
Merchants.
Merchants are missing from this
picture, and that takes
us to principle number four--
merchants are a key part of the
ecosystem, and, again, I'm
going to give you two reasons.
First merchants are a great
source of specialized data.
They are the ultimate
specialists on their line of
business, and also on the
community their operating in,
so they should be part of your
data crowdsourcing mix.
The second reason is what is
it merchants want the most?
Customers, exactly.
So they want customers so they
can sell their products and
services, but who are
those customers?
Users.
Very good.
I mean, it's pretty
obvious, right?
Users, customers--
their customers are the users
of your application, so if
you're running a highly
specialized application,
they're going to be a really
good match between the
merchants and the users, so your
app will be sitting at a
really interesting spot between
merchants that are
trying to sell and consumers who
may be willing to buy if
well informed and
incentivized.
And that's the reason why you
have to try to engage
merchants into your service,
that's the reason why
merchants are a key part
of the ecosystem.
All right, so those are
the principles.
Right, so now Andres and I are
going to go through the steps
of actually using those
principles and using the
Places API to try to build
an actual location based
application.
Are you ready, man?
ANDRES: I'm ready.
I'm ready.
So as Marcelo mentioned--
or as I mentioned, I
guess, as well--
we're really keen on building
and designing a surfing
application that accommodates
all of these things, and with
that I think we should
gear up, right?
We should really take it
to the next level--
MARCELO: Let's do it.
ANDRES: --and gear up for
building our application.
MARCELO: I've been waiting
for this moment.
ANDRES: I mean, you can't really
say you're going to
design a surf app if
you're not going
to look like a surfer.
MARCELO: You look good, man.
ANDRES: All right.
By the way, I wanted the
red shirt, but Marcelo
said he wanted it.
MARCELO: So just before we go
into the key requirements, I
want to tell you why we've
chosen to build a surf app.
So the reason number one-- we
wanted to build a specialized
app, right?
Lead by example.
And although I wouldn't call
ourselves specialists in surf,
we're both surfers and we're
really at least a little bit
knowledgeable and really
passionate about the subject.
The second reason is I wanted
to do something that is
outside of what you usually
think when you think of
location based applications.
I didn't want to stick with
suggesting restaurants or
hotels, and I think surfing is
probably out of the comfort
zone for most people
here in this room.
And, lastly, I wanted
to have fun.
ANDRES: You did want
And I will say, though, when I
put together my 100 plus page
requirements document--
and I think it included a lot of
features you quickly shot--
MARCELO: Well, we only
have twenty minutes.
--a lot of them down.
ANDRES: Yeah, I guess
so, I guess so.
All right, so let's talk about
the key requirements, Marcelo.
MARCELO: All right, so
requirement number one--
I want to allow my users to
find nearby surf shops--
sorry, surf spots--
I mean, that's the basic
functionality--
ANDRES: That's a no-brainer
for surfers.
We need that.
MARCELO: --for any location
based service, right?
But that's not enough.
Just knowing where the surf
spots are is not enough.
As a surfer, I also want to know
what the surface looks
like right now, and in
the near future.
So the second key requirement is
the ability to provide surf
reports and forecasts.
ANDRES: Of course.
We don't want to head out there
if we know the surf spot
but we don't know what it's
going to be like, I mean it
could be a flat day.
MARCELO: I mean, it does cost
money because you have to pay
for the gas, at least.
But just the basic requirements
are not enough.
Those will be enough for me to
go to a friend of mine, a
surfer, and show his app, I
wouldn't be embarrassed.
But I want more than that, I
want to surprise my user, I
want to delight them, I want
them to actually be talking
about the application to
their friends, right?
Because that's the best type
of marketing tool you can
have, so I want some magic.
ANDRES: Where do you put it?
MARCELO: I want some magic.
ANDRES: During our design
meetings you want some magic.
MARCELO: Are you happy
with that?
ANDRES: Almost.
Almost, Marcelo.
See, you always get to talk
about the fun stuff, but then
I have to bring things
back to reality--
MARCELO: [? You're my weed, ?]
man.
ANDRES: --We need the profit,
we need to pay the bills at
the end of the day.
MARCELO: Fair enough.
ANDRES: We especially need to
build up that war chest for
that surf safari that we're
going to go on after we--
MARCELO: I'm sold.
ANDRES: --After we finish
building this application.
So profit is an important
part of it, as well.
MARCELO: So right, how do you
make money out of this
application?
OK, so the first task is how do
you list nearby surf spots
using the Places API.
So what I'm doing here
is I'm calling the
nearby search endpoint.
And all I'm doing-- it's
really simple to
use, as you can see--
I'm providing a location, and
which happens to be in my home
turf, back in Sydney, and a
radius of two kilometers.
And when I execute that search,
bang, I get back a
bunch of places.
Can you see any surf spot there
on that results, Andres?
ANDRES: None of the surf spots
that you and I have hit any
time that I've been in Sydney.
MARCELO: Yeah, so there's no
surf spots there, and the
reason is really simple--
Google doesn't index
surf spots.
And Jeff is here, maybe he can
work on indexing surf spots in
the future, they'll be really
useful for surfers all over.
So yeah, Google doesn't index
surf spots, so how do I solve
this problem?
So there was where specialized
knowledge comes in, I know the
area really well, so I can
list those sports myself.
So what I have here is a list of
all the surf spots just in
the Dee Why area.
Just a name and the location.
So I'm going to use the data,
and I'm going to fit it into
the Places API using
another endpoint
that's at a place endpoint.
So I just go,
maps/api/place/add, it's a
POST request, I'm parsing
the CSV file over there.
Setting up the request, we
just place the surf spot
location and the
name, and bang.
ANDRES: But Marcelo-- and I
need to interrupt you real
quick just to point
something out.
I mean, this is a representative
sample of code,
right, for the Python script
that we wrote to get
the data out there.
But what I want to mention is,
it actually wasn't that much
more code, I think it was
less than 20 lines of
code that we wrote.
When we were sitting down we
were sort of surprised, we
were kind of like, I mean,
I think we kind of
wanted to code more.
MARCELO: The Places API is
really simple to use, really
simple to learn, and that can
actually always be a challenge
for us to come up with
an interesting
presentation about it.
ANDRES: All right,
so what next?
MARCELO: So now I'm going to
redo my place search, and now
the only thing I'm adding is the
types=other there so that
the only thing I'm going
to get back is the
surf spot that I added.
ANDRES: Right, and that's
because, as you mentioned
before, we don't have a place
type called surf spot.
MARCELO: Unfortunately,
we don't have a surf--
ANDRES: At least not yet.
MARCELO: Yeah, not yet.
ANDRES: All right, so here are
the surf spots we added.
MARCELO: Yeah, can you
recognize them?
ANDRES: I do, I recognize almost
all of them, and I want
to point out that there is this
one surf spot, and let me
highlight it actually.
That place here, and--
MARCELO: It is quite
far away, isn't it?
ANDRES: Every time that I've
been to the Sydney office, and
Marcelo and I have gone surfing,
he's actually never
mentioned this surf spot.
You want to tell folks
what you told me?
MARCELO: Oh man, you don't
want to go there.
ANDRES: Yeah, you want to tell
folks what you told me?
MARCELO: That's called
Bombie and it's a
big rider surf spot.
You've got to step up your
game, man, before I
can take you there.
Honestly, I don't want to see
you crying like a baby.
ANDRES: Just for the record,
last time I was not crying, I
was just whining, and
I think there's a
big difference there.
So just keep that in mind.
All right, what next?
MARCELO: OK, so now we've listed
the surf spots, what we
want to do is actually also
provide the surfing
conditions.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use a US government
website that provides current
and forecast data about
weather and ocean
data, as well.
So I have my service set up like
this, I have a cron job
that goes regularly and fetches
that data, the most
recent run from the US website,
matches the data
against the surf spots I have
on my database, and uploads
the result into the Places API
so that the next time a user
does a search you're going to
get back the wave forecast for
that specific surf spot,
attach it to the data.
And this is how I--
so what I'm doing here,
actually, is I'm using the
event endpoint in a very
creative way because it wasn't
really designed for this type
of use, but, I mean, you can
use it however you want, and I
hope my PM's not here, oh he's
[INAUDIBLE].
All right, so what I'm doing
here is I'm attaching an event
to the surf spot, but instead
of describing the event in a
summary, I'm using the summary
to attach the wave data--
the surf ratings--
for now and the next few hours
for that surf spot.
And when I do my search again,
for each surf spot I'm going
to get the event attached with
the data there, so I can
easily display it on
my application.
ANDRES: OK, so we've got the
beginnings of a pretty good
app here, right?
And we've incorporated some
of the principles that we
discussed before, this is a
highly specialized app, right?
It's a surfing app by surfers,
for surfers.
Actually, we need
to brand that.
But the other thing is we've
gone beyond the base data,
we've added our surf spots, and
in addition to that, we've
also added some value to the
user by providing some
additional context, and that's
essentially the surf forecast
and conditions.
MARCELO: So we can tick off
two principles so far--
specialized, and go beyond
the base data.
ANDRES: Yeah, so if we take a
look at our surf spots now, we
get a pretty good indication of
whether we should head to
the four star surf spot or not,
I mean, that's kind of a
no-brainer.
But that's not really
enough, right?
MARCELO: No.
ANDRES: This is a nice app, it's
compelling, I'd probably
use it, but we need
to go beyond that.
This is where the magic
that you were
talking about comes in.
MARCELO: So now I want to
surprise my user, I want to
delight him.
I want to get him really engaged
with the application,
I want him to return to my app
on a daily basis because I
want to turn this into a
business, so I want this
relationship to be a long term
relationship with my user.
So I want to get to know him
better, I want to get to
understand him, understand
his preferences.
So what I'm going to do here,
I'm going to offer the option
for him to check in and out of
the surf spots, so before you
go into a surf session, you
check in, when you come back,
you check out.
It's not really hard, I actually
check my phone every
time I go for a surf, and when
I'm back I want to know what
time it is because
I've got to work.
And so I think that's something
that users--
that surfers-- would actually
get to use.
And in return of the check in
and out, I'm going to offer
him something.
What I'm going to offer him is
some analytics about his
surfing practice.
Maybe I can show him what are
the surf spots that he hits
the most, or I can show him
the average length of a
surfing session.
And I'm pretty sure this will
be compelling for most
surfers, I would definitely
use it.
Would you?
ANDRES: I definitely would and,
again, I need to point
out that you did want
to call these
analytics something, Marcelo.
You want to tell everybody what
you wanted to call them?
MARCELO: I would like to
call it Surfalytics.
ANDRES: Surfalytics, folks.
You heard it here first.
So we're gathering a lot of data
for the user, and that's
really beneficial for the user,
but what if we take it
one step farther and we start
taking that data at aggregate,
and now using it to provide some
additional information to
our other users.
So one of the things that
surfers hate the most are
crowded surf spots, so if we
know that folks are checking
in, we could allow folks to kind
of get a sense for how
crowded a particular
surf spot is.
So, for example,
Dee Why Point.
Marcelo, if there were 17 people
that checked in in the
last hour to Dee Why Point--
MARCELO: No, you don't want
to go to Dee Why Point.
It's a point break that can
take 10 people at most.
So I'll definitely use that
feature, I could see myself
using that future to
decide where to go.
ANDRES: Cool.
MARCELO: But now that I
know my user, right?
I want to go beyond there, I
really want to surprise him.
So I know where he's going for
surf, I know the time that
he's going for surf, and I know
the kind of surfing that
he likes-- is he a big rider?
Does he like middle sized waves,
or tiny little waves
like my friend here, Andres,
different people like
different kinds of waves.
So what I want to do is I want
to pop-up a notification on
his phone saying, hey, there's
a good surf session coming up
in the next couple days, maybe
you want to prepare yourself.
And if he clicks through the
notification, he'll get a
notification landing page where
he can see what the
prediction conditions are.
ANDRES: In this case,
they are epic.
That's right.
MARCELO: Conditions are epic.
And set up an alarm, or
set up a reminder--
plan himself--
or he can just say, you
know what, I won't be
able to make it.
ANDRES: I'm going to be up late
tonight coding, and I'm
probably going to be too tired
to go surfing tomorrow.
MARCELO: So I can
see the campaign
right here, Sweet Surf--
don't ever lose a epic swell
again, or something like it.
ANDRES: Yeah.
Well, I think we're moving in
the right direction here, but,
again, coming back.
We've covered all the fun stuff,
Marcelo, but we have to
come back to the things
that I talked about--
paying the bills.
So we need to--
MARCELO: You're like
an anchor, man,
you're like an anchor.
ANDRES: We need to incorporate
commerce into our application,
and we really want to
do it in two ways.
The first way is our users are
consumers, and they're
interested in goods and
services, as Marcelo
mentioned, so we want to use
the Places API to show them
goods and services that
they're interested in.
So what are surfers
interested in?
Surf shops, probably surf
schools, right?
So we could easily use the
Places API and the standard
search functionality, and two
of the key features here.
The ability to filter by
keyword, and the ability to
rank by distance.
Now we've been referring to this
amongst ourselves as a
commodity search.
So if a surfer is searching for
something, say like surf
wax, they don't really care
which shop they're going to go
to, they just want to find the
nearest surf shop so that they
can get the wax, wax their
board, and get
on about going surfing.
So here's a demo that shows a
search which uses the default
results, these are the top
five results ranked by
prominence.
And what we can do is if we rank
them by distance, we see
that the radius shortens, and
we actually see that places
are a lot closer to the
origin of our search.
Subsequently then--
and now we're talking about
the base data, right?
Subsequently then, we can
present something
like this to our user.
Now imagine that--
as is often the case--
if you've been out there and
you've been really pushing
yourself, like I do, and you've
been riding some pretty
big waves, sometimes your board
gets dinged and you want
to get a repair.
So enter the merchants.
There's nothing stopping us from
giving merchants access
to our application and allowing
them to use the
events feature to add time based
incentives, in this case
offers, for their target
audience, for surfers.
So now if I do the same
type of search--
this commodity search--
there's a differentiator there,
and there's something
that's probably going to drive
me, and I can see that, hey,
if I just drive a little bit
farther I'm going to drop off
my surfboard, and I'm going
to get a discount on the
surfboard that I'm going to rent
to go out there and hit
the 20 foot waves that
I typically surf.
All right, so I think
we've brought it all
together now, right?
We've incorporated a lot of
the key features, we've
touched on all of the principles
that you were
talking about, I actually
snuck something
else in here though.
So today we announced the
support for reviews in the
Places API, and so there's
another type of search that we
can enable for our users as
well, which is more of a
qualitative type of
a search, right?
So if I'm looking for a surf
school, I'm less concerned
about how close it is and
more concerned about
the quality of it.
So I can provide search results
based on the Places
API that look more like this
where a user can see how a
particular surf school
is rated.
And then they can actually dig
in a little bit deeper, and
see what people are saying
about that surf school.
Is it the type of surf school
that they want to take their
family to, for example.
MARCELO: You've got to keep in
mind there is always a trade
off between the time your user
is allowing to invest in
searching, and the cost of
making a wrong decision.
So the higher the cost of making
a wrong decision, the
more time he will invest
in doing a search.
If he's searching for a surf
school, he wants, not the
cheapest, he wants the best
experience, so the cost of
making a mistake in choosing a
surf school is high, so he'll
spend more time doing
that search.
The cost of making a mistake
when choosing a surf shop to
buy wax is none, so he will
just do what we called a
commodity search.
ANDRES: All right, so we've
talked quite a bit about our
sample app, Sweet Surf, and
this is really not the end
though, I think this is
just the beginning.
Something that Marcelo touched
on at the beginning is that we
envision an ecosystem off
location based apps.
So we are providing a platform,
but we're really
counting on all of you all to
take it to the next level, to
take that step and start
building applications that
connect users with merchants,
that allow merchants to
provide that quality engagement,
that quality
commodity, as you put it.
MARCELO: Yeah, absolutely, and
also we just started with API.
It's going to go a lot further
in terms of functionality, and
in terms of the data, and
in terms of the quality.
So with that I'd like to thank
you guys for attending on
behalf of the Places API team,
and we're going to open the
mics for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDRES: Do we have the number
of check-ins for
a particular place?
MARCELO: We do have, but
we don't expose that to
applications.
So the idea of the check-in
is it's only--
you're providing a signal of how
relevant that place is to
your users, and we use
that signal when
we're ranking results.
So currently we don't
provide any
information back about check-ins.
Currently.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MARCELO: No.
And one of the reasons
is privacy concerns.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a couple of questions.
The Places API-- is it still
bound to the same licensing
scheme as the Maps API
for commercial
applications, calls?
MARCELO: So we have
our PM here, Thor.
ANDRES: Yeah, we're going
to call our PM up here.
Put him in the hot spot.
Just kidding.
THOR: Can I borrow your mic?
ANDRES: Of course.
THOR: We're going to
get personal now.
ANDRES: That's right.
MARCELO: We are very
close, Gene.
THOR: Increasingly
so, it seems.
ANDRES: [INAUDIBLE].
THOR: OK, perfect.
OK.
ANDRES: [INAUDIBLE].
THOR: Thank you, OK.
So the Places API is considered
part of the Maps
API family, so it is subject to
the existing Maps API Terms
of Service.
There are a few small
differences that are peculiar
to the Places API.
For example, most of the Maps
APIs there is a requirement
that you must use the service
in conjunction with a Google
Map, the Places API you can
actually use it without a
Google Map as long there is an
alternative which is a small
Powered by Google logo
that you use instead.
Although what you can't
do is use it with
other provider's maps.
So we've seen a lot of mobile
location based apps that don't
need a map, they just need to
show people places nearby to
let them check in, and, in
that case, that's fine.
However, also another small
difference is that in the web
based Maps API, you're not
permitted to use the free Maps
API in a full-fee application,
one that you sell for money.
A caveat to that in the Maps
API Terms of Service that's
often overlooked is that that
does not apply to mobile apps
sold through online app stores,
such as Google Play or
the iTunes app store.
So many of these location based
apps that use the Places
API fall into that category.
But beyond that, with the
restrictions that we have
regarding things like use in
private applications, those
kinds of restrictions
do still apply.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the second question I have
really deals with your
implementation of
the surf app.
You all had a small number of
points, so you could deal with
it in a way that's much easier
than dealing with a large set
of data, so let's say I'm
looking at all the restaurants
in the US, what immutable piece
of data comes back from
the Places API can I use to
bridge that to data in my
custom database?
MARCELO: So for every request,
every result you get back from
the Places API you've got an ID
and that ID is constant for
that place, for the life
of that place.
But that's what you have
to use to map it
back to your database.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: On the Maps API, will
there be functionality or
at least a flag for us to
determine whether or not a
business has been claim
by the owner?
THOR: There is not that
functionality right now, but
it is something that we are
interested in looking into,
and also in helping you
understand whether the owner
of a business is also a user
of your application.
AUDIENCE: Can you say that
last part, I'm sorry.
THOR: Something else that we're
investigating is the
possibility of helping you
understand whether the owner
of a business is also a user
of your application.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if you
could speak a little bit
about the concept of hierarchy
of places, do you guys have a
concept of hierarchy and what
are you doing around that?
MARCELO: You mean a hierarchy
of types?
AUDIENCE: Specifically, Moscone
might have multiple
conference rooms inside
of it, for example.
MARCELO: No, the Places
API currently has
no notion of hierarchy.
We do have-- that's one of the
reasons why we added events.
I mean, it's not the same thing,
but you could add--
in the case of Moscone,
you could add a room
as an event, right?
You would have a time to leave,
but it would work for
the case, for instance,
of a conference.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
MARCELO: So if we have no--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I'm just experimenting
with it, and I
just did a search for "cafe"
as well as your
classifications, and I was
hoping that the icon would be
a picture of a cup, and it
always comes back a fork and
spoon, and I'm just wondering
if that's because--
MARCELO: When was that test
that you run, just now?
Because we just fixed
that bug yesterday.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
THOR: I should stress that's
entirely coincidental, we
don't just leave all the bugs
until the day before I/O.
ANDRES: Great
THOR: I'll just mention that
we do also have a fireside
chat our last session tomorrow,
so if you have
broader questions about the Maps
APIs generally, including
the Places API and any of
the other features or
announcements we've made over
the course of today and
tomorrow, and that's a great
opportunity to spend an hour
grilling us mercilessly.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDRES: Thank you.
MARCELO: Thank you.